Keith's with us in New York City hi
Keith how are you I'm good how are you
sir
better than I deserve what's up well my
wife and I are a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars in bit and right now
I'm kind of curse you know what to do we
have car loans they have a lot of
different things going on and it's lost
I understand I'll know where to start
sounds like a little overwhelming how
much break that debt down for me how
much is owed on the cars okay on the
cars we have 53,000 okay so you've got
about 70,000 and other stuff what is
that okay we have credit cards that are
what about fifty five thousand credit
cards okay and excuse me the other debt
is time care tape time share okay you
don't have student loans no one else
doing loans so that's good news
what's your household income yeah well
right now we bring home about eighty
four hundred dollars a month
good okay cool and are you putting money
into your 401 K s now a couple of
dollars yes okay all right and are you
living on a budget yet no not yet all
right is she as overwhelmed and
frustrated and scared as you are yes yes
because what happened was she decided oh
we can get a new car and we went in
leased a new car and that kind of hurt
okay well it everything you know I heard
a guy tell me one time he was talking
about just being successful in general
he said the problem with setting goals
that cause you to become successful is
not what you're willing to do to hit the
goal it's really it's what you're
willing to give up you know I'll work my
butt off that's one thing but what am I
willing to give up and if you want to be
debt-free making $130,000 a year which
you guys are
five thousand dollars a year and be
debt-free you're gonna have to give up
some stuff and I don't know if you're
scared enough to do that yet or not
that'll be up to you these are emotional
personal decisions now I know having
walked in the you know walked in this
personal finance stuff my wife Sharon
and I for for 40 years now 35 years now
and walked with millions of people
literally without exaggeration over the
last 25 years I know where you'll end up
if you'll do these things so it's real
easy for me to give up your stuff okay
but I because I can see the end of it
for you I can see how you're gonna win
but I don't know if you can see that yet
or not see I can see that with the kind
of money you make you could be 100
percent debt-free and be on the path to
being a millionaire you know in about a
year and a half a year and a half yeah
but I've sold both of your cars yeah
yeah I'll see what I did see you want
this knife back yeah reach around behind
your back it's between your shoulder
blades do you know because see I don't
leave you know you don't you sell it you
just sell it and cover the lease and car
you know you'll have a you'll be upside
down you have to cover some upside down
and but you make a ton you make so much
money and you're so broke it's so
pitiful yeah I just don't want that for
you man I want you to win and so I know
you'll get me if you'll drive like no
one else later you can drive like no one
else I know if you live like no one else
later you can give and live like no one
else because I've done it and I've seen
so many other people do it but you're
kind of brand new to this whole idea but
the deeper you sacrifice the faster you
win you know it's like it's like this at
a retire in five years
yeah well you
you're broke I know you know so we gotta
do something different no way it's up to
you how radical you want to get but the
more radical you get the more radical
your results are gonna be in a good way
hold on I'll send you a copy of the book
the Total Money Makeover it'll shock
your system even more